malgré le départ des troupes américaines
au mois d'août dernier il reste encore
des traces de leur présence ici à kaboul
comme par exemple ces quelques magasins
où l'on trouve toutes sortes de choses
en provenance des bases américaines sur
le sol afghan vestes pantalons
chaussures casquettes sacs à dos mais
aussi jumelles couteau boussole sacs de
couchage de véritable caverne d'ali baba
ça vient de la base de bagram sa date
d'avant quand il y avait la guerre et
maintenant ça se vend et c'est ce que
beaucoup de gens achètent
essentiellement pour la pêche et la
chasse et puis il y a des marchandises
qu'on achète pour faire des cadeaux des
t-shirts avec afghanistan marqué dessus
toutes sortes de choses qu'on offre en
cadeau principalement il existe aussi
quelques témoignages de la contribution
française à cette guerre en afghanistan
comme cet insigne bleu blanc rouge ou
encore se porte clés aux couleurs de la
france et de la force internationale
d'assistance et de sécurité sous
commandement de l'otan dans certaines
épiceries on retrouve aussi de la
nourriture à l'origine destiné pour les
troupes us
comme par exemple ces rations de soldats
ou encore plus surprenant
des queues de homard
depuis le temps les américains étaient
ici chez nous c'est resté je ne sais pas
comment mais les gars les ont récupérés
à bagram et depuis on les vend et nous
les vendent et nous les mettons sur le
marché
mais depuis le départ définitif des
américains le filon se tarit
les affaires et bien on ne se plaint pas
mais bon ce n'est plus comme avant la
présence de ces bases us sur le sol
afghan générer toute une économie
parallèle qui disparaît donc peu à peu
en attendant il reste encore quelques
bonnes affaires à faire